[Music]
hi mystery recapped here
today i'm going to explain an american
science fiction comedy film called meet
dave
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins with a small glowing
object in space heading towards earth on
its way to the planet it knocks into a
satellite and enters the atmosphere in a
new york city apartment a young boy
named josh morrison stares through his
telescope at the object falling from the
sky the golf ball-sized metal ball flies
through josh's window and lands in his
fishbowl the ball seemingly drains the
water along with the goldfish as josh
watches in amazement the movie then fast
forwards to three months in the future a
massive fireball makes its way towards
the earth and crashes next to the statue
of liberty on liberty island when the
flames subside the fireball is revealed
to be a man wearing a white suit he
walks awkwardly and takes a ferry back
to the city the man navigates through
the city seemingly amused by humans
while crossing a road he gets knocked
over by a car
the accident twists his foot but he
quickly disappears before the lady
driver gets to call an ambulance in a
secluded corner the man's right ear
opens like a gate and out comes a tiny
humanoid alien the tiny humanoid slides
down a rope to the man's legs he opens a
tiny window in the man's leg revealing a
bunch of malfunctioning wires the tiny
humanoid then begins to repair the leg
another tiny humanoid notes the status
of the leg and returns to the brain of
the man it turns out the man is a
spaceship controlled by 100 tiny
humanoid aliens
its captain pilots the spaceship from
the command deck located in its head and
humanoids controlling one body part each
send a report back to the captain
the report reveals that the ship's
impact shields were not activated
because of the unpredicted nature of the
collision but the ship has survived
however it will only be able to run at
full capacity for the next 48 earth
hours
the ship's tracking systems were also
damaged the captain assembles the crew
for a briefing he reveals that they come
from a planet called nil their planet is
on the verge of a catastrophic energy
crisis and the ball-like device called
orb which they sent to the earth three
months earlier was lost
they are here to retrieve and deploy it
salt from earth could power planet nil
for ages the aliens plan to use the orb
to take earth's salt by draining earth's
oceans the captain has second in command
named number two and a researcher named
number three as advisors by his side
the spaceship looks like a human but the
aliens don't know how to make the ship
act like a normal human they use google
and yahoo to learn about humans
meanwhile the cops are alerted about the
mysterious fireball a superstitious
officer named dooley and his partner
begin investigating the matter
they learn from the impression of the
man's face in the dirt on the crash site
what he looks like and orders his search
throughout the city elsewhere josh
notices the human spaceship from his
window and alerts his mother gina who is
the same female driver that knocked it
over
gina rushes downstairs and apologizes to
the human ship the aliens slightly panic
over their first verbal encounter with a
human captain attempts to talk through
the ship but ends up speaking in an
extremely high frequency breaking
glasses nearby
after adjusting the base and frequency
the captain manages to respond that he
is okay gina sends josh to school and
invites the human spaceship to her home
captain introduces himself as dave ming
chang based on a quick scan of common
earth names
the crew notices their missing ball in a
photograph in gina's home
gina reveals the images from josh's
school when josh took part in a science
fair it turns out josh presented the orb
as his science project
the crew quickly locate josh at 729 east
44th street and david excuses himself
and proceeds to leave
however he mistakes the closet for the
door he then awkwardly steps out of the
closet and leaves through the door as
dave walks his way through the city to
josh's school number two gets
increasingly agitated by humans
disregard for rule and order captain
asks an onboard doctor to keep an eye on
number two due to his increasing
eccentricity dave passes through a
children's park and kids mistake him for
an ice cream man so dave changes his
clothes to pay for the new clothes he
scans money and literally prints it out
from his arse
dave finally arrives at the school
looking for josh's class the school
principal mistakes him for a substitute
teacher and sends him to the class while
teaching dave takes josh outside the
classroom and talks to him about the orb
josh tells him that the ball was taken
from him by his bully rich who will be
at a street fair tomorrow the captain
decides to go to the fair with josh the
next day and they then return to josh's
home as they spend more time with each
other josh grows to like dave he is
amazed by dave's video game playing
abilities when gina arrives home she
asks dave if he would like to stay for
supper number four reminds the captain
that the longer they stay in their
presence the greater the danger of
exposure but the captain decides to stay
after the supper dave asks gina about
the painting on the wall she reveals she
drew the painting while she was in love
and it depicts passionate love
dave is intrigued and confused
he asks how do you know when you feel
love gina responds that when you feel
love you don't need to ask that question
dave is still not sure but excuses
himself to leave for the night dave
decides to spend the night on a homeless
man's spot the homeless man offers dave
his blanket to keep him warm dave is
pleasantly puzzled by the man's act of
kindness the aliens realize that humans
are more advanced than they originally
thought
as the ship retires for the night the
doctor reveals that an atypical behavior
is spreading throughout the ship the
captain finds number three working late
into the night she reveals that she has
discovered an interesting file in the
alien database that every human is
forced to watch once a year the file is
an iconic american christmas movie in
the movie the hero offers to lasso the
moon for his love interest the captain
and number three find themselves sobbing
after watching the movie they feel drawn
towards each other but suppress their
urges and go to bed the next day with
only 20 power left and police looking
for him dave goes to the fair with josh
to retrieve the orb dave participates in
a hot dog eating contest and wins it he
receives a soft toy as a prize and gifts
it to gina gina is elated to receive the
soft toy dave later finds rich bullying
josh he lifts the bully upside down as
josh is elated to see rich learn a
lesson after dave retrieves the ball he
offers to take gina and josh to a
restaurant to celebrate gina's birthday
number two protests and suggests that
they start deploying the ball instead
however the captain argues that gina and
josh have helped them retrieve the ball
so it's only fair that they return their
favor number two storms out of the
control room in protest as dave takes
gina and josh to a salsa restaurant
where they are having an amazing time
meanwhile the police have located dave
and are on their way to apprehend him
after spending so much time on earth
most of the crew begin to exhibit new
feelings adopting earth's culture
mannerisms and general laid-back
attitude number three learns that number
four has turned his whole room into a
dance club number three then also
changes into a salsa dress and goes to
the control room to ask the captain to
dance with her but gina asks him to
dance before her number three hurt
leaves as they dance the police arrive
and apprehend dave for questioning josh
and gina are puzzled by the arrest as
officer dooley interrogates dave number
two decides that the captain and the
rest of the crew's changing behavior is
unacceptable and gathers an army of
aliens for a coup d'etat captain enraged
orders the crew to not comply with
number two however realizing they are
short on time to rescue their planet nil
the crew including number three oblige
with the new captain the two cops
overhear the conversation inside dave's
control room because of an open speaker
officer dooley's suspicion of dave being
an alien solidifies and the two cops
leave the interrogation room number two
then announces that under his leadership
a new era has begun and unnilion
behavior will be punished dave the
spaceship then storms out of the
confinement blasting through the wall
police officers spray dave with bullets
but it barely has any impact on him
seeing the number two get out of control
number 17 a young fun-loving drunk alien
jumps out of the ship to save himself
from his fury on dave's way out number
two notices josh and gina he berates
them for wasting his time with their
emotional pathetic distractions finally
he tells gina that her artwork is
pretentious before leaving number two's
craziness worries number three and she
sneaks back into the alien quarters and
frees the captain however number two
soon catches up to them and sneezes them
out of the spaceship as the tiny aliens
attempt to avoid being trampled on by
humans and peed on by dogs number three
lets the captain know her displeasure
over him choosing to dance with gina
over her the two then use a plastic bag
as a hot air balloon to fly towards the
spaceship however the plastic bag gets
stuck in a bus's windshield wiper they
then use the wiper as a launcher to
propel themselves on the spaceship and
land on dave's shoe the captain then
apologizes to number three telling her
that he chose her to accompany him on
this mission because of her giant heart
and kindness without her he would be
nothing she then asks him why he never
spoke to her like this and the captain
responds that he was too nilian to ever
express it he expresses regret that he
should have lassoed the moon for her a
long time ago the duo then makes their
way back into the ship meanwhile dave
takes a cab to save his energy to
liberty island josh refuses to believe
that it is dave who is doing these evil
things and convinces his mom to follow
dave and help him back at the police
station dooley discovers number 17 in
his coffee and interrogates him to find
out where dave is going at the liberty
island harbor as number two proceeds to
throw the orb into the water to drain
the earth of all its water and salt
captain overrides his command and stops
him number two is enraged and orders the
crew to apprehend the captain along with
number three however the captain tells
the rest of the crew that the real
captain is in charge again wary of
number two's unpredictable and eccentric
nature the crew accept the captain as
their leader reinstated he orders number
two to be stuck in the ship's butt
forever the metal orb meanwhile slips
out of dave's hand and rolls into the
ocean the siphoning process starts and
the orb begins to drain the ocean the
captain attempts to retrieve the orb but
is told that they only have enough power
left to either retrieve the ball or
return home the captain makes a decision
to save the earth and asks the crew's
permission they all agree and dave
reroutes all its energy to stop the
siphoning process after retrieving the
ball dave powers down while dooley and
his partner catch up and point their
guns at him josh grabs dooley's taser
which he uses on dave recharging him
after dave gets fully recharged the
captain and number three reveal
themselves to the police officers who
stand down the captain says goodbye to
josh and gina saying that he now
understands love the captain resolves to
find other sources of energy on other
planets instead of destroying the earth
number 17 is then returned to dave by
dooley as dave proceeds to fly back to
his planet the fbi arrives and traps
dave in a net while the fbi agents
wrestle the body down dave's crew
evacuates to one of the ship's lifeboat
shoes activates the engines detaches the
shoe and heads home to nil leaving
behind both the ship and number two
while in the lifeboat the captain asks
for number three's hand in marriage the
movie ends as she accepts and they kiss
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching